Reino Unido tiene una nueva primera
ministra y residente del número 10 de
Downey Street listas hasta el momento
ministra de exteriores logró vencer a su
rival y a verse con el liderazgo del
partido conservador
presentaré un plan Audaz para reducir
los impuestos y hacer crecer nuestra
economía me encargaré de la crisis
energética de las facturas energéticas
de los ciudadanos pero también de los
problemas a largo plazo que tenemos con
el suministro de energía
con su Victoria se convierte en la
tercera mujer Primera ministra en la
historia de Reino Unido que tuvo un
importante papel en el gobierno del
Primer Ministro saliente Boris Johnson
Enhorabuena alis tras por su decisiva
Victoria sé que su plan para hacer
frente a la crisis del costo de vida
unir a nuestro partido y continuar con
el trabajo de unir y equilibrar a
nuestro país es el adecuado ahora es el
momento de que todos los conservadores
la apoyen al cien ahora tras deberá
enfrentarse a la crisis en el costo de
vida al malestar en el sector industrial
y a la recesión económica y guerra en
Europa una difícil tarea para la que
hasta su rival rishizunak ha prometido
respaldarla he dicho que los
conservadores somos una familia lo
correcto es que nos unamos y sigamos a
la nueva primera ministra listross
mientras dirige el país en tiempos
difíciles tras asumir al cargo Este
martes como primera ministra y dirigirá
los siglos políticos de Reino Unido al
menos durante dos años más